is a new brand on the scene called alif
they make hundred percent halal raw cat
food there are countless health benefits
to this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at alif dot uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get 10
discount on their two week trial box
with my cold ali10 check them out now
and let your cat enjoy some nice food
assalamu alaikum guys today we're gonna
do a little social experiment where
we're going to be asking questions the
question how people feel about the war
the invasion the occupation and the
killing of innocent people that's been
happening let's see what reply we get
yeah so how do you feel about the war
the occupation uh then the invasion
that's happening
putin he's sick i'm talking about
palestine oh are you yeah
you said the war yeah why is that is
there not is there one happening in
palestine an invasion or occupation okay
so how do you guys feel about the war
the invasion the occupation and the
killing of innocent people that's
happening
oh
i think it's disgusting yeah it's wrong
why is putin doing this putin's doing
this because he's doing it sorry yeah
putin is doing it how do you feel about
the war the occupation the invasion and
the killing of innocents happening um
it's pretty rough i mean at the end of
the day ukrainians haven't done anything
to russia again i don't know well
ukrainians haven't done anything to
russia okay guys so how do you feel
about the common war the invasion and
the occupation that's happening
i mean it's it's it's not the best
situation for anyone really it's
devastating just to say what's actually
happening
in life who do you think is that blame
here
and eyes don't he's committed war crimes
who else
vladimir putin patient that's happening
on the killing of innocent people how do
you feel and who do you think is to
blame
okay how do you feel about the war that
invasion the occupation and the killing
of innocence um i feel what i've read
there's no real reason why he should
have evaded ukraine i've been watching
you a lot and i don't agree with the
stuff you've been doing let's ask the
question turn around please
lady gaga how do you feel about the
current war that's happening
she thinks
we support ukraine it's hateful what to
do yeah
who who's the who's to blame
oh no probably russia
how do you feel about the war the
occupation
and the invasion that's happening myself
it's a bit scary in it like um
you know there's a bit of a threat to us
over here you know it's a they've got
them over here you've never well i mean
there's the nuclear threat isn't there
um i'm talking about palestine
what's happening with ukraine is
disgusting as muslims we're against any
kind of oppression towards anybody but
i'm talking about palestine i was just
talking about palestine in this specific
experiment so i'm talking about
palestinians sorry i talked about
i mean i'm talking about palestine
like what's happening in palestine yeah
ukraine is well that's terrible hundred
percent oh well that's the point is uh
oh sorry i'm talking about palestine oh
yeah what's happening
what's happening now what's happening
with ukraine i'm 100 with you it's
terrible it's disgusting but also
there's wars going on besides israel
like in palestine i'm sorry i'm talking
about palestine sorry oh so sorry yeah
what's happening ukraine is absolutely
disgusting uh and we're against it as
well but we're just talking about this
other wars happening as well so with
palestine you know israel the occupation
the killing and the innocent i'm talking
i'm talking about palestine oh palestine
oh yeah i'm from ireland i'm from
ireland from ireland no i've got family
in afghanistan
i feel like they are being ignored you
know ukraine is in the spotlight russia
i'm talking about palestine oh yeah i'm
not here no i'm talking about palestine
oh i thought it was over
now ukraine is terrible as well what's
happening there totally against it but
also i'm not so sure because the media
doesn't really cover it we're talking
about palestine over here what about
palestine sorry yeah sorry we're talking
about the ukraine oh yeah that's that's
happening as well as current and it's
terrible what's happening as well but uh
like with palestine and you know kashmir
foreign india has been occupying kashmir
as well oh no i don't know much about
them regards to that i think with what's
going on in palestine it's kind of being
overshadowed by what's going on in
ukraine and maybe that's because
the culture here is mainly
westernized and people don't care as
much about what's going on over there
away from this story yeah the reason
i've done that i was intentional i doubt
that because the thing is the moment we
mentioned war invasion occupation
killing the first thing people come
their mind is ukraine rightly so but the
palestinians have been forgotten that's
the reason i'm doing this because the
moment at the moment i mentioned
you know supporting ukraine and we
forget about palestine don't we so
what's your name what's your name my
name is anne-marie just america you know
the reason i did this because the moment
i asked a question and say how do you
guys feel about war occupation uh
occupation and killing they say ukraine
i'm like of course i'm talking about
palestine
exactly palestine you know we still need
to be aware that palestine is you know
it's still a huge thing that people need
to still be known and made aware of so
all i can say is free palestine how do
you guys i can ask you guys a question
how do you feel about the media's racism
because i've been watching the media i
know if you guys were watching it but
they use was like for example these are
blonde head blue-eyed children we're a
civilized nation these things happen in
third world countries do you not feel as
if it's as if they're trying to tell us
that the bombing happened in third world
countries is okay but what happens in
europe isn't do you not think that's
dehumanizing human beings definitely i
think in
[Music]
that country it's made more normal for
it to happen whereas in ukraine it's
more of a shock exactly yeah yeah just
not talked about enough
it's because it's in europe
in your forefront and you're and you're
worried it could happen to you whereas
when it's in middle east
anywhere else
my son is half afghan and it was
happening in afghanistan you know
they're also being forgotten about and
as you know tony black he went to war
um
with the iraqis and actually lied about
weapons of mass destruction it's no
worse than that
a hundred thousand iraqis were killed as
well that's interesting because the
moment the many people that we
interviewed the moment i'll mention war
occupation the first thing they think is
ukraine
but you talked about different ones
saying that the war in ukraine with
putin is no worse than what i'm tony
blair and joshua bush did with iraq that
what about people in palestine in yemen
and different people parts of the world
for example how do you feel about the
racism in the media because like there
was one of the
presenters were saying that basically
these are blonde head blue eyed children
dying and i thought what does that mean
blonde hair blue eyed of course whoever
dies is a child i don't categorize
childs to black hair brown eyes so do
you think there's some racism in the
media yeah well that's that's evidence
anyway not even justin we're going if
you're going on war in palestine
it's not right at all um any sort of
thing like that is not right exactly um
and i feel that it should be stopped
right away
in the right way though
um so how do you guys feel about the
current war the invasion and occupation
that is taking place well it's not it's
not very good at all honestly but like
i've got like an idea of how we can like
give boosts like morale and get like it
out there into like the public because
it's not really known to quite a lot of
people here because it's like not it's i
mean it's on the news but like the
palestinian was not on the news as much
as ukrainian war
but like i feel like i feel like
implementing it into media would be
really good so like it's good game's
very interesting it's a really hitch
show like it's got like millions and
millions of views on netflix if you like
implement like bits of like the war and
what's happening into the show and like
can i just make it people get awareness
of it and they know what's happening i
think israel is called caused more
crimes than nazis ever did yeah since
second world war yeah yeah palace uh
israel yeah and i i i do feel sorry for
the palestine state yeah i mean i went
to school with people from palestine
interesting okay years ago back in the
seventies okay which is well that's the
point because the reason why the moment
i mentioned war occupation invasion the
first thing that comes to our mind is
ukraine yeah i'm which rightly so yeah
i'm from cyprus so i'm next to it so i i
heard a bit about it but it's not as
documented as it should can you see
people are dying here palestine's awful
man i mean it's been going on for a long
time
i don't know as much about as i should
do but
it's it's i mean from what i've heard
about it it is
horrendous and um israel needs to be
able to account more
do you why do you think the moment i
mentioned war invasion occupation
that ukraine is the first thing that
comes our minds which is important and
it should know you're right it's just
because i think this is so pertinent at
the moment because it's so current but
you're right it shouldn't be the first
thing that comes to mind there's wars
going on everywhere across the world
i've known about the media's bias they
always talk about stuff but they don't
talk about
like they're talking about russia but
they ain't talking about the middle east
exactly that's my point you know is the
europeans life's more dearer than than
than you know the people in the third
world country they're all the same they
everyone
should be the same for everyone yeah and
they're just focused on russia and just
russia yeah
they ain't talking about middle eastern
or nothing but putin yeah
so what country was it they put out they
said a billion pound to kill him i'll do
it i have no idea
for free i'll i'll do it for free
brother okay i'm at it give me a dress i
don't know
russia i have no idea not find it for me
yeah i dead him off brother i don't
think you get the point here we don't
need to carry on further you know as you
can see the double standards we are not
doing this to undermine what's happening
in ukraine you know uh because i'll be
honest with you um i probably maybe
dislike
russia
putin i'll say so i say put in more than
the president of ukraine um
so i why because at the end of the day
even though the ukraine ukrainian
president
is um somebody who's supported israel
you know but i don't um think he's
directly uh killed innocent muslims
putin has so this is just to show the
double standards of the media hope you
enjoyed it share with your friends and
family until next time salaam
alaikum wabarakatuhu